Good morning, William; it's Friday, March
4, one of the very few dates that's also a
sentence... March forth!
Today, we're gonna take a voyage into the
dark heart of contemporary narcissistic megalomania
by playing "Sheen or Gaddafi?"!
The rules are pretty simple, Hank, I'm gonna
tell you a series of quotations and you're
going to guess whether that quotation was
said by Charlie Sheen or Muammar Gaddafi.
However, for the purposes of making the game
challenging, I will be translating Muammar
Gaddafi's quotations from Arabic, because
otherwise it'd be really... easy to figure
out, you know. "Is it in Arabic?" would be
the primary question you would be asking.
Okay, let's just play!
Your first quotation, "Every great movement
begins with one man, and I guess that's me."
Who said it: Sheen or Gaddafi?
Time to guess. Just click on whoever you think
said it. By the way, you might wanna turn
on annotations; I mean, if you're still watching
this video, it's presumably because your annotations
aren't on. Turn them on! And then click "Sheen"
or "Gaddafi."